a las dos de la tarde hora de Washington
llega Volador a la casa blanca será
recibido por Joe biden a las dos y media
de la tarde hora local de Washington
será esta reunión bilateral que durará
aproximadamente dos horas para que a las
cuatro y media de la tarde también en la
casa blanca
y el presidente ofrezcan una rueda de
prensa tras la culminación de la rueda
de prensa Volador
transportará hasta el congreso allá dará
un discurso en la plenaria del Congreso
ante republicanos y demócratas y el
objetivo de este discurso es
precisamente asegurar el apoyo y
partidista esto teniendo en cuenta que
pues en campaña
el próximo presidente de la cámara de
representantes Pues dijo que iba a
cortar la ayuda militar y la ayuda en
defensa a Ucrania palabras que también
han repetido varios representantes a la
cámara del partido republicano Esto
entonces este discurso
precisamente va en línea de que el
congreso apruebe para el 2023 el
presupuesto de ayuda militar de casi
40.000 millones de dólares se espera que
yo bailen también hoy haga un anuncio de
ayuda adicional militar a Ucrania por
dos mil millones de dólares y en este
paquete de ayuda se incluye también en
las baterías que pues incluso llevarán a
que soldados ucranianos vengan a Estados
Unidos para que aprendan a usarlas para
poder defenderse en Ucrania de los
ataques rusos